well joining me now is former white
house press secretary and host of the
political talk show spicer and co on
newsmax
sean spicer very good evening to you
sean spicer well what do you think about
these
attempts by the democrats to clip the
president's wings in his final nine days
in power they believe he's
such a threat to the nation that he
needs to go now
well good evening to you i mean look i i
this is a serious situation what
happened last week
it's frankly troubling it was disgusting
it was heart-wrenching to watch what
happened on
capitol hill last week and i think that
the the democrats
know that this is a political response
that they're giving the president united
states is leaving office
in nine days there is no 25th amendment
that's going to be invoked that's a
silly discussion
because no member of the cabinet has
said that they are entertaining it
the vice president has said through
aides that he's not entertaining it
with respect to impeachment the house
could probably get through a very rushed
procedure because
the democrats control it but currently
and up until at least the 20th
the senate democrats excuse me the
senate republicans are in charge of that
chamber
so we know that this isn't going
anywhere and it's purely a stunt on
behalf of the democrats
which i think is really not an
appropriate response to this because you
shouldn't
be making light or trying to make a
political statement with what happened
last week
there are serious concerns about what
happened how it happened
who should be held responsible and
making sure it never happens again and i
think clouding this in a way that's
going to further divide the united
states
and really do nothing to move the ball
forward really shows the naked
political aspirations of some on the
democratic side certainly plenty of
questions there to address as you put it
but with these final nine days in office
with all the powers of the commander
in chief there are worries about what
the president might continue
to try to do do you share any of those
do you have any
links into the white house now do you
know the president's mood do you get a
sense of
whether he's given up we saw that video
he delivered on thursday evening
saying that the full force of the law
would be used against those that
attacked the capitol building some said
it seemed more like a hostage video
do you have any sense of the president's
mind at this point
i don't i have not spoken to him since
the events of last wednesday
i will say however that again i mean
impeachment is a political tool and
that's what is being used right now by
the democrats
i understand their desire to appease
their base but the reality is
that again we're nine days from this we
know the political outcome of either one
of these avenues that's available
and neither one of them produce an
outcome that's serious
so the reality is that by the day that
they actually get this thing moving
forward
the senate is not meeting again until
the 19th of january
right so that just shows you the reality
of the situation
that we know it's not going to happen so
you could be as concerned as you want
in theory but the reality is is that the
the legislative calendar doesn't allow
for this to occur
prior to the president leaving office at
noon on january 20th
and just your thoughts sean spicer on
what
the president was up to last wednesday
that extraordinary sequence of events
the speech he made to the crowd
then they marched on the capitol
building the lack of security
surrounding the capitol building in
particular federal
security none of that there it seems and
then none
called in for several hours and the
extraordinary letter
sent the day before by the 10 living
defense
secretaries warning the military not to
get involved do you think the president
actually made an attempt somehow
to get the military of the united states
of america to support his ambition to
stay in power
there's a lot to unpack in that question
and i mean i i think that
in the days and hopefully the months to
come we take a lot a lot and
hard look at each one of those things
particularly
the concern about security at the united
states capital we're seeing reports come
out today i haven't confirmed them
independently
that the police chief for the capitol
police
had asked for support from both the
house and the senate
uh sergeant-at-arms who oversees the
chamber security in both of the
respective
houses of congress you know that should
set red flags up why wasn't that call
for help
listened to or heated by those two
respective chambers
there's going to be a lot of look
especially as we head towards this
inauguration on january 20th
to make sure that the proper precautions
are being taken taking place
but but i i mean i will say this that as
an american
i you know if you had told me the day
before that fellow americans
were going to rush the capital of the
united states and break down barriers
and go through security and
break windows and harm people i i would
have told you that that was unfathomable
we haven't had attacks on our country
like that
in our history i mean they are from
outside they are
al qaeda attacking us um and an outside
interest attacking us on 9 11.
it you know you go back to japan
attacking us in world war ii
these are not things internal uh
threats that we have seen in our country
the likes of which we saw
last wednesday and so i i think it's
very difficult in some cases to look and
say how could you not have seen this
because we hadn't we never thought of it
as an american to think of another
american attacking
our own institutions in the way that
they were last wednesday is something
that if you had told me tuesday or
wednesday morning
you know i bet you these folks are going
to do this i would have said there's no
way
this isn't something that any american
does to an institution like the capitol
so i think it was a shock to the system
a shock that
is going to be examined and looked at
and and you know discussed for quite
some time to come
especially in light of a major security
event like the inauguration is coming up
and that letter that extraordinary
letter from the
10 former secretaries of defense
to the military to stay out of domestic
politics
they clearly got wind of an attempted
coup
oh i look i i with all due respect i
think
the use of the word coup i i don't know
why they wrote it but i i think that
that is a a very serious
use i look as someone who served in the
military
uh i i think that our troops have a an
obligation and an oath most importantly
to the constitution of the united states
we don't take a
an oath in the military to a leader to a
party we take it to the constitution
and every officer and enlisted
individual that i've ever known
would by by the code of our military
justice system
would never execute an unlawful order
sean spice uh great talking do you
appreciate you sparing the time
thank you so much you bet thanks for
having me